kim kardashian she was honored in new
york last night this was kim's first
public appearance since her happy
halloween weekend with pete davidson but
kim's priority had nothing to do with
pete
i just had a little fashion emergency
kim's sleeveless brown leather dress
unzipped just after she stood up to pick
up her wsj magazine brand innovator
award coming to the rescue designer kim
jones and demi moore thank god i had
skims under or this would have been a
different kind of show tonight
there was no sign of pete three days
after the pair's just friends halloween
hand-holding but still kim was in good
company
i'm so honored to be a part of this
class with them we did a little
trick-or-treating was great ryan
reynolds all about his halloween with
blake and the kids and with wsj
magazine's award he's kind of the king
of innovation for acing acting and
business um boy you know i certainly
wouldn't call myself the king of
anything but i i i uh i'm deeply
inspired by storytelling i think
storytelling extends to the business
world as much as it does to showbiz
where i sort of cut my teeth started and
it's still my bread and butter but
i love storytelling storytelling's a
huge part of innovation for me
also at the awards martha stewart
sharing her secret to looking ageless at
80. homemade green juice from things i
grow
demi who's equally age-defined at 58
wore a low-cut fendi suit paul walker's
daughter meadow hit her first red carpet
since getting married and still looking
for love little nauseas who had a black
leather dachshund as his plus one you
gotta see my little bag did little bag
have a name
yes luna
i know somebody who's fun somebody who's
always like ready to try new stuff yep
single and ready to mingle but for now
the 22 year old rapper is just enjoying
time with family before this year like
my family was like okay you make music
that's dope and then they like actually
get into the music and they love it as
much as me so that's fire
yeah but i'm like turning it off like
not right now
[Music]
you